The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
Today we are going to continue
with chemical equilibrium.
And, at the end of the lecture,
Professor Ceyer will be here to
talk about exam two.
We are going to start off where
we left off, and we were talking
about Le Châtelier's principle.
Le Châtelier had this great
idea that systems tend to
respond to stress in a
particular way.
That if you apply a stress to a
system at equilibrium,
it will respond to that stress
by trying to minimize the
stress.
The reaction will respond to
adjust for the stress that was
applied and minimize that
stress.
If you consider what stress is
applied to a reaction and then
how that stress can be
minimized, you can predict
whether the reaction will go in
the forward direction or the
reverse direction.
And so it tends to go in one of
those directions to minimize the
stress until the stress has been
minimized, and then equilibrium
is reached again.
We talked last class about
adding and removing products or
reactants and how the system
would respond.
And today we are going to
consider changes in volume to a
gaseous system and also
temperature and how systems
respond.
And at the end we will talk
about the relevance of this to
biological systems.
Again, here is Le Châtelier.
We can use this to predict the
direction of the reaction,
the response to the stress that
is applied.
First let's consider what
happens if you have a mixture of
gases at equilibrium.
They are reacting.
Again, in equilibrium,
it is a dynamic process.
You have the reaction going in
the forward direction and the
reverse direction,
but the rates of those
reactions are the same,
so there is no net change in
composition, but the reaction is
still happening.
Now, if you have a system at
equilibrium, a gaseous system in
equilibrium and you change the
volume, it will consider how the
reaction will shift to
compensate for this stress.
So a decrease in volume of the
gaseous system will cause an
increase in total pressure.
How do we know that?
What equation tells us about
pressures and volumes of gases?
Yeah, ideal gas law,
PV equals nRT.
That is what we will be
considering today.
Le Châtelier's principle would
predict that the system will
respond in such a way,
then, to reduce the total
pressure.
If you decrease the volume,
increase the total pressure,
the system is going to respond,
then, to reduce that total
pressure, to minimize that
stress that was added into the
system.
Let's look at an example.
Here we have two P two gas
going to P four gas,
so two molecules of P two going
to one of P four.
And in the middle one here,
we have this system at
equilibrium.
And we are going to consider
both what happens when we
decrease the volume and when we
increase the volume.
First let's consider this
decrease.
What happens is that a decrease
in volume shifts the reaction
toward products.
Why is that true?
Well, it has to do with the
stoichiometry of this equation.
For every two moles here that
are consumed,
only one is formed.
A shift to the right,
toward products,
is going to reduce the number
of molecules in the system,
and therefore reduce the total
pressure.
When you have a decrease in
volume, that initially causes
the total pressure to increase.
And so the system responds in
such a way to minimize that
stress and decrease the
pressure, which you can do by
shifting this reaction toward
products or to the right.
This is what Le Châtelier's
principle would allow you to
guess when you look at this
particular reaction.
And you can also prove to
yourself that this is correct by
considering Q and K and delta G.
Let's prove that this is what
would, in fact,
happen.
We consider again Q and K.
Remember that this is what is
important in both of these two
lectures.
We are talking about Q,
the reaction quotient,
the ratio of products to
reactants under whatever
condition you are at that
particular moment in time.
Whereas, K is our equilibrium
constant, the ratio of products
to reactants at equilibrium.
Now, to make the math easy,
let's assume that the volume
decrease happens by a factor of
two.
You decrease the volume by two.
That is going to initially
increase the pressure of both
gases of P two,
the reactant,
and P four,
the product,
by two, so the partial pressure
is going to go up.
Now we can figure out by how
much with this decrease in
volume.
Q, again, the reaction
quotient, is products over
reactants, so our product,
partial pressure of P four over
the partial pressure of P two
raised to the two.
Again, you consider the
stoichiometry when you are
writing your equation for Q or
for K.
If we work this out,
we find that by decreasing the
volume by a factor of two,
Q is now half what it was.
It is decreased by a factor of
two.
Now Q is less than K.
We were at equilibrium before,
but if stress was applied,
the volume was decreased.
And now we have a situation
where Q is no longer equal to K,
Q is less than K.
And so that is going to then
shift the reaction toward
products.
It will be spontaneous in the
forward direction.
You can just sort of
rationalize what will happen,
and you will have questions on
homeworks and on exams saying,
if this stress is applied,
predict how the reaction is
going to respond,
you can work it out in terms of
thinking about Q and K or just
sort of rationalize how do you
minimize that stress that has
been applied to the system.
And if you are asked how much
happens, if numbers are given,
you can actually work this out,
what Q is at that point and
what K was.
Now, if we increase volume,
if we go in this direction,
what is going to happen?
Well, the reverse will happen
in this case.
We are going to shift toward
reactants.
For every one mole of product
that goes in this direction,
in the reverse direction you
will form these two moles of P
two.
A shift toward the reactants,
a shift to the left is going to
increase the total pressure.
If you increase the volume,
you are initially going to
decrease the partial pressure.
And a shift in this direction
of the reaction will compensate,
it will increase that partial
pressure until you reach
equilibrium again.
Because you are going in a
reverse direction from one to
two moles.
Again, we could work this out
in Q and K.
Actually, we will do this at a
later example.
But, again, you can rationalize
or figure it out in terms of Q
and K and what delta G would be,
positive or negative,
which direction the reaction is
spontaneous, in the forward
direction or in the reverse
direction.
All right.
Let's make this a little bit
more complicated now and
consider what happens when you
add an inert gas into that
mixture.
Here we are adding an inert gas
into the container.
And when we add it,
it is increasing the total
pressure of that container and
temperature is constant.
Add an inert gas.
Increase the total pressure.
What is going to happen to the
reaction?
Will it shift to the left or
the right?
What is going to happen?
The answer is in this case
nothing.
Why?
Why won't this affect the
equilibrium?
Why aren't we affecting Q here?
The answer is that Q depends on
the partial pressures of the
gases involved,
and partial pressures are not
changing.
The total pressure is changing.
But the partial pressures of
those gases are not changing.
At this point,
let's review partial pressure,
and then I think this will make
a lot of sense.
The definition of partial
pressure is the pressure that
each gas would exert if it were
alone in the container.
Here we have some oxygen at one
atmosphere, here we have
nitrogen at one atmosphere,
and here we have a mixture of
the oxygen and the nitrogen.
And now that we have added one
gas to the other,
the pressure is two
atmospheres.
We added one atmosphere of this
and one atmosphere of that,
and we have two atmospheres
total.
But if you are asking about the
partial pressure,
say, of oxygen,
the partial pressure of oxygen
is the same here as it is in the
mixture, because partial
pressure is the pressure that is
due just to that particular gas,
as if it were alone in a
container.
Let's look at the equations for
partial pressure.
And, if you haven't had partial
pressure before in high school,
I said this is a review,
but this is actually everything
you need to know about partial
pressure for this unit,
so it doesn't really matter if
you haven't seen this before.
If we have our familiar ideal
gas law, the partial pressure of
A depends on just the number of
molecules of A in that container
at a given volume.
The total pressure of a system
will be the partial pressure of
A plus B plus C,
depending on how much of a
mixture you have.
In this case,
we have a mixture of O two and
N two,
so our total pressure is two.
But our partial pressure of
each of these gases in here is
still one, as it was before when
they were alone.
How is this all relevant?
Well, it is relevant because Q
depends on the partial pressure,
not the total pressure.
The question you have to ask
yourself in looking at all these
problems is, is the partial
pressure changing,
i.e., is Q changing?
Because only when Q changes
will equilibrium be affected.
In the particular example that
I gave you at the beginning
here, I asked,
what happens if an inert gas is
added to a container,
increasing the total pressure
at constant temperature?
And so the answer was nothing,
because Q is not affected.
The partial pressure for the
gases is still the same.
The volume has not changed any.
You have not added more of
these two gases.
You added an inert gas so the
number of moles of these are the
same.
The volume is the same,
so the partial pressure is the
same.
And if partial pressures are
the same, then Q is unaffected,
so Q does not change.
It doesn't matter.
There is no shift because Q is
still equal to K.
We are still under these
conditions.
It seems like it is a stress
applied, but it is not really a
real stress, so there is no
change.
Let's look at another scenario
and consider what will happen.
Now, what happens if we add an
inert gas, but the total
pressure and the temperature are
kept constant?
The total pressure is not
allowed to change,
it is kept constant.
For this to be true,
for you to add two things
together and the total pressure
doesn't change,
what had to have happened?
Volume had to have changed
here, otherwise this couldn't be
true.
The volume had to change.
Because here we have your
constant temperature,
we have the gas constant here,
number of moles.
If we have increased this
number of moles,
and then the total pressure has
to be affected by it.
If it didn't,
that means volume had to have
changed for that to be true.
For the pressure to be
constant, the volume of the
container must have increased.
And so you will notice,
in working a lot of these
problems, often it won't say
anything about the volume.
It will tell you about the
pressure, and you have to figure
out whether that means there was
a volume change,
because the volume changes are
the ones that are relevant.
It is all sort of in the
wordings of these problems.
All right.
The volume must have increased,
otherwise the pressure would
have gone up.
Then this question really is,
what happens when the volume
increases?
And we know how to answer that
question already.
For this particular reaction,
where you have these two P
two's going to one P four,
an increase in volume
means that you are going to
shift two reactants,
you are going to go from this
side that has one to this side
which has two.
That way, when you increase the
volume, the partial pressure is
going to drop.
You want to respond in a way to
minimize that stress,
which means you want then an
increase in the partial
pressure.
Again, we can think about this
in terms of Q and K.
Then we just work a little
example on the board to
emphasize the point.
We did the other example
earlier, but now let's consider
if your volume doubles.
And my picture doesn't make it
look like it is doubling but
this makes the math easier.
That means if the volume
doubles you are going to half
the partial pressure,
initially, of both gases,
of P two and P four.
And so now we consider Q
because it is really all about
the relationship between Q and
K.
Q is going to equal the partial
pressure of the products over
reactants, and the reactant is
partial pressure of P two.
Again, with the stoichiometry,
that is squared.
If the volume
doubles, initially the partial
pressure will be half for the
products and also half for the
reactant P two,
and that is squared.
So, Q is twice what it was
before.
Now Q is greater than K.
And so you will have a delta G
that is positive,
which means you are going to be
spontaneous in the direction
toward reactants.
And you could sort of just
reason that out by looking at
the number of moles on one side
or the other.
Or, if you want to convince
yourself, you can look at Q and
K, because this is really where
it comes from.
When Q equals K,
you are at equilibrium.
If it is greater than K,
then you shift.
Question?
Yeah, just because it doubles.
There could be real numbers
that you are looking at,
but this is just considering if
you double this then you are
going to have a decrease.
Yeah, it's a partial pressure.
The number of moles are not
changing but the partial
pressure is changing because the
volume is changing.
All right.
Yeah?
Well, at equilibrium Q is equal
to K.
That Q and K are both products
over our reactants or the
partial pressure of products
over reactants.
When you make some change like
this, Q was equal to K,
but now you have a change.
Either if you increase or
decrease, then it changes the
relationship to your equilibrium
so you are no longer in the
equilibrium conditions.
At equilibrium Q equals K by
definition.
You are always considering,
if you are talking about
applying a stress to a system,
you are assuming that the
system was in equilibrium.
And then you apply a stress to
that situation that is at
equilibrium and ask how does
this system respond?
In all of these questions,
you are under equilibrium
conditions and then you apply
the stress.
So that's volume.
And so the secret to these
problems is asking,
is the partial pressure
changing under those conditions
when you are talking about
volume.
You had a system at
equilibrium.
Then you messed up your system
at equilibrium by compressing
the container or increasing the
container.
And whether you added an inert
gas, it really always falls down
to those two possibilities that
the volume was decreased or the
volume was increased.
You have to look at the
question and read carefully and
say what is happening to the
volume under these cases,
and then you can figure out
which direction it is going to
go.
And, of course,
that was all one example.
You have to look at what the
particular reaction is,
how many moles are on one side
and how many are on the other,
to think about this.
Le Châtelier also works for
temperature.
In this case,
you are thinking about what
happens if you raise the
temperature of an equilibrium
mixture.
The reaction mixture is at
equilibrium, delta G equals
zero, Q equals K,
and now you are changing
something.
You are changing the
temperature.
Raising the temperature by
adding heat will cause the
reaction to shift,
so that that heat is absorbed.
This is the same idea.
Applying stress to the system,
raising the temperature,
the reaction is going to
respond so that the heat that
was added is now absorbed.
You go back to where you
started.
Le Châtelier works for
temperature as well,
it is the same idea,
but here the stress is changing
the temperature of the system.
Adding heat or removing heat
from the system and thinking
about how that reaction that was
at equilibrium is going to
respond to this stress.
Let's consider an exothermic
reaction first.
An exothermic reaction,
if we are raising the
temperature of an exothermic
reaction, you will favor the
formation of the reactants.
Why is that true?
Well, with an exothermic
reaction you are producing heat.
And in the reverse direction
you would be absorbing heat.
According to Le Châtelier's
principle, you want to respond
to minimize the stress.
If you raise temperature,
you want to shift in a
direction where that heat will
be absorbed.
So a shift, then,
in the endothermic direction.
And so for an endothermic
reaction, it is just the reverse
of this.
For an endothermic reaction,
you are absorbing heat toward
products and producing heat
toward reactants.
If you raise the temperature of
an endothermic reaction,
you will favor the formation of
products.
Because, again,
if you are adding heat,
you want to absorb the heat so
it will shift the reaction in a
direction that absorbs the heat.
Let's consider this a bit
further.
In this case,
delta H is our predictive tool.
If we know delta H,
we are going to be able to
predict the direction that the
reaction is going to go.
Before, we were talking about
delta G as being our indicator.
Here delta H is telling us
quite a bit about what is going
to happen, i.e.,
whether the reaction is
exothermic or endothermic.
Let's just do a quick example.
Here is a reaction,
delta H, negative 197.78
kilojoules per mole.
Is that an endothermic or
exothermic reaction?
Exothermic reaction.
If heat is added,
if the temperature is raised,
what direction will it go,
toward products or reactants?
Reactants.
It will want to absorb that
heat, so it goes in the
endothermic direction or the
reverse direction.
That is pretty simple.
Delta H allows us to make that
prediction.
All right.
We need to think now about the
relationship between temperature
and equilibrium constants.
Equilibrium constant has been
constant up until this point,
but now we see that temperature
will change the equilibrium
constant.
The ratio of products to
reactants that you have at
equilibrium will depend on
whether it is an exothermic,
endothermic reaction and how
much heat is in the system,
the temperature that the
reaction is being run at.
You will get a different
equilibrium constant,
a different ratio of products
to reactants if you are at one
temperature versus another
temperature.
And also, we will come back to
this at the end of the course,
reaction rates depend on
temperature.
How fast those reactions go
depends on temperature as well.
All right.
Now we want to figure out
exactly how equilibrium
constants depend on temperature.
And to do that,
we have to think about what we
know in terms of equations that
have temperature in them and
have equilibrium constants in
them.
We know that delta G nought is
minus RT natural log of K. We
also know that delta G nought is
equal to delta H nought minus T
delta S.
Now, if we want to take that
information and combine it and
solve for the equilibrium
constant in terms of delta H --
And we want to do that.
We want to solve for in terms
of delta H and in terms of
temperature, because we want to
think about delta H,
endothermic,
exothermic reactions and the
relationship between equilibrium
constant and temperature.
If we just rearrange these
equations that you have already
seen and should be reviewing now
for exam two,
you can come up with this.
Now we want to think about
which of these terms are
temperature dependent.
I have already told you that
the equilibrium constant is
temperature dependent.
Delta H here and delta S,
we could assume that they are
pretty much constant over any
temperature that we would be
looking at, any temperature that
a reaction would be run.
These guys are not really
changing.
And so if they are not really
changing, then we can see that
the equilibrium constant is
going to change with respect to
the change in temperature.
As we change temperature,
K will vary here.
And we can look at this for two
different temperatures.
If you change the temperature
of the system,
the first temperature and the
second temperature,
T one and T two,
they will be different
equilibrium constants at these
two temperatures,
different ratios of products,
two reactants at these
different temperatures.
If we write out two equations
then, one for K two with T two,
so the equation for the second
temperature and the equation for
the first temperature at T one
and the first equilibrium
constant for that particular
temperature.
And then if we subtract these
two equations,
so if we subtract the natural
logs of the Ks,
we can express that in terms of
natural log of K two over
K one.
And if we subtract the second
part, we subtract this from
this, the delta S over R terms
are going to cancel out,
they are the same,
delta S is not changing with
temperature here,
and so those two terms would be
the same, they are going to go
away.
And now what is different are
these two temperatures.
We can pull out the negative
delta H here.
We can pull out the one over R.
And that leaves one over T two
minus one over T one.
And it has a name so you know
this must be an important
equation.
That is partly how you can
tell.
It is the van't Hoff equation.
It tells you how the
equilibrium constants are going
to change with temperature.
Now let's look at how the
numbers are going to work out if
we have a negative sign here,
i.e., if it is an exothermic
reaction, or we are going to
have a positive delta H,
so that would be an endothermic
reaction, and whether you are
adding or removing heat.
There will be a difference in
the ratios of K one to K two.
Let's think about what comes
out of this equation and
rationalize it.
This looks a little
complicated, but it is actually
pretty simple.
Here, all we are doing is
saying, what if delta H is
negative?
If delta H is negative and we
have T two greater than T one,
well, this negative sign here
is going to be negative all the
way through here.
It is always present.
That is part of the equation.
Delta H now,
if it is negative,
you will have a negative here.
And then we consider the
different between one over T two
and one over T one.
And, in this case,
if T two is greater than T one,
that is a negative.
When you multiplied all those
out together we would have a
negative here.
That is just what is all done
there.
Now let's rationalize that this
makes sense.
This is just the same thing but
has a little more
rationalization in it.
It puts things in words instead
of using the greater and less
than thing.
And these parts are not written
in your notes,
but if you want to add the
words to it, that is fine,
on the handout.
And you can just think about
this on your own as well.
If delta H is less than zero,
negative number,
you have an exothermic
reaction.
What happens if you increase
the temperature of an exothermic
reaction?
Let me just put those back up
on the board for a minute.
For an exothermic reaction,
we are talking about reactants
going to products.
In an exothermic reaction heat
is produced in the forward
direction and heat is absorbed
in the reverse direction.
If we increase the temperature,
it is going to want to go in a
direction to compensate for that
to absorb the heat,
so it is going to go toward
reactants.
And so you are going to have a
K one that is greater than
K two, which means at the
new temperature you are going to
have less products or more
reactants.
And we can rationalize why that
would be true.
And, if you don't want to
rationalize it,
you can always take the van't
Hoff equation and figure it out
by looking at the different
signs and what it would mean --
What is going to happen in
terms of that ratio of K one to
K two when you have this
particular condition.
Now, if you decrease the
temperature of an exothermic
reaction, then it wants to
compensate by producing more
heat.
You decrease the temperature.
It wants to respond to the
stress to minimize the stress.
The way to minimize the stress
is produce more heat,
so you will make more products.
Now for the endothermic
reaction, it is just the other
way around.
Reactants going to products.
Here, heat is absorbed.
And in the reverse direction,
heat is produced.
Now, if we have our endothermic
reaction and we increase
temperature, we are going to
shift to our products,
because we are going to want to
absorb that heat that was just
added, minimize the stress.
And, for an endothermic
reaction, if we decrease the
temperature, then,
we are going to shift it to
produce more heat,
i.e., toward reactants,
so we will have less products.
And we would have K one that is
greater than K two.
You can use the van't Hoff
equation to rationalize the
prediction of change,
or, if you are given numbers,
you can say the exact amount of
change.
If you are given a K value at
one temperature and said if we
change this temperature,
if we increase it,
this is what delta H is,
what is our new equilibrium
constant?
You can use the van't Hoff
equation to come up with direct
numbers, or you can use it to
just rationalize the direction
of change.
If you have less time on a
test, you can also just think
about what might be going on
here, and predict without
working through the numbers.
Now, we are going to apply what
we just learned to think about
how it can be used.
You want to think about the
shifts that we talked about last
class and the ones today have
options of adding and removing
products or reactants,
changing volumes,
changing temperatures.
This is quite an important
reaction, and we talked about
this last time,
nitrogen gas plus hydrogen gas
going to ammonia.
It is an exothermic reaction.
If it is exothermic and you
want to drive it toward ammonia,
which is what people do.
They want to make ammonia and
want to what is called fix
nitrogen.
Ammonia is used in fertilizers,
lots of nitrogen in the air,
but you don't want it in the
air, you want it in your soil
for growing better crops,
so you want to do this
reaction.
You want to maximize the yield.
Then it seems like the low
temperature would be good.
It's an exothermic reaction so
low temperature would be good.
It would favor product.
But there is a problem with
that, which is that low
temperature also slows the rate.
And you usually want a good
rate.
You want to make a lot of
products pretty quickly,
make some money off of it,
so you have to balance here.
Sometimes the thermodynamics
and the kinetics are working
against each other.
What would favor one doesn't
work so well for the other.
They have to have a compromised
temperature, which is actually
quite a high temperature of 500
degrees Celsius.
There is a little bit of a
problem there.
The temperature thing isn't
working for us.
What are some other things that
they could do to drive the
reaction toward products?
What else could you do?
Okay.
I am hearing a couple of
different things.
I am looking for one other.
What about --
A couple things that you could
do that would work,
I think I heard most of them
now.
Remove products as they are
formed.
If you remove this product that
would drive it toward more
products.
And so one thing that they
actually do is every once in a
while stop the reaction,
cool it all down and liquefy
the ammonia gas.
The liquid pours off and then
you remove this product and then
you make more product.
If it reaches equilibrium,
you pull off the product and
then it makes more.
And I also heard about this
compressing the volume of the
container because over here the
reactants, there are four
molecules that are reacting to
form two, and so that should
also shift in the correct
direction to make product.
They actually do these at this
pretty high temperature,
and they have to apply a really
high pressure to compress that
volume.
This is expensive.
And it requires a lot of
energy, actually,
to do this reaction because of
the conditions that are required
to maximize the yield.
Again, why this is important,
there is a lot of nitrogen in
the air, however,
it is really stable.
And you could probably tell me
why it is so stable if you draw
a nice Lewis diagram of it.
It is difficult to break these
apart, so that is why this is a
hard problem.
Because you want to break this
bond to have usable nitrogen,
and it is challenging to do.
The process,
which I just described to you,
is one that was developed quite
a long time ago.
This reaction is called the
Haber-Bosch process and is
responsible for generating
1.6x10^10 kilograms of ammonia
each year in the U.S.
for fertilizers and other
things.
And it was developed by these
two men right here.
Haber came up with the initial
idea, and Bosch helped figure
out the appropriate conditions
to get the maximum yield.
All they are doing is basically
using some of the principles
that you have already learned in
this course.
And they both won Nobel Prizes
for being part of this process.
This one initially and this one
later on.
I will also mention that this
is an interesting man if you are
interested in sort of history of
science.
He is a German chemist,
and during World War I he
switched his effort from
fertilizers to coming up with
different kinds of poison gases
that could be used in warfare.
But he was not rewarded
favorably for this later on
because he was also Jewish.
In 1933, he had to flee
Germany, despite all that he had
done for the war effort,
earlier on.
He did not live too long a life
after that.
But this was developed a long
time ago and is still used.
Some scientists are actually
trying to figure out how to do a
better job.
They figure any process that
really started to be developed
in the 1800s and kind of refined
in the 1900s,
maybe we could do better.
Again, a lot of energy is
responsible, high temperatures,
these extreme pressures for the
condensed volume.
Maybe we could figure out a way
to do that same reaction without
those extreme conditions that
require a lot of energy.
And so a number of scientists
have looked to an enzyme,
a protein found in bacteria
that does the exact same
reaction as what is done
commercially,
but it doesn't use any high
temperatures or any high
pressures.
A number of scientists are
trying to figure out how this
protein works.
How it is able to do this
reaction so efficiently.
Here is a space filling picture
of the enzyme,
and here are metallo-clusters
that do the actual chemistry.
And so orange is iron and
yellow is sulfur.
Blue is nitrogen.
Red is oxygen.
Gray is carbon.
This purple color here is
molybdenum.
These are metals that are used
in biology to do particular
kinds of reactions.
And this just shows a little
bit more about the cluster sort
of in the heart of this protein
molecule.
And all the chemistry happens
at the metals,
but it is surrounded by a lot
of protein.
That is one effort that a
number of scientists are
venturing on.
Often we find varied forms of
bacteria have proteins that do
reactions that we want to do,
and they do it much better than
we do them.
And so we want to understand
how that works.
And this is one example.
It turns out,
this is quite complicated,
and scientists still don't
understand the exact details of
the reaction mechanism at that
metal site.
Another attempt is just to
pretend that,
you know, to move away from
nature.
And Dick Schrock's lab here at
MIT has been able to do this
reaction using a sort of
designed catalyst that has
molybdenum in the center.
You have probably heard the
name Dick Schrock because he won
the Nobel Prize in chemistry
just a few weeks ago.
He didn't win for this.
This is another one of his
contributions.
All right.
Really quickly,
I want to give just one more
biological example.
And then we will hear more
about exam two.
Again, as I will emphasize in
this course.
All the things you learn can be
applied to biological systems as
well.
The same basic principles.
Here we have hemoglobin.
Hemoglobin is the protein in
your body that carries oxygen
from the lungs to the cells.
And you can write the reaction
for hemoglobin and oxygen the
way you can write any of the
reactions we have written.
Hemoglobin plus oxygen goes to
oxyhemoglobin.
Here this is just oxygen bound
to the hemoglobin.
Now let's consider what happens
if you decide to climb a
mountain.
The partial pressure of oxygen
is different at sea level;
it's higher than it is in the
mountains.
As you go up to higher
altitudes, the partial pressure
of the oxygen decreases.
What does this mean in terms of
this equilibrium?
Which direction would it shift
if the partial pressure of this
is decreased?
Yeah, you are going to shift
toward reactants,
which means you have less
oxygenated blood,
you have less oxygen bound.
And that is not good.
It makes it much harder to get
energy to climb that mountain,
so that is not good.
Usually, if you are going to go
climb a mountain,
you have to adjust,
you have to acclimatize.
How many people are mountain
climbers?
Anybody?
A few people.
You usually have to get up and
wait for a while before you can
start climbing.
What actually happens is your
body is making more hemoglobin,
so you have to wait for this to
happen.
And, if it makes more
hemoglobin, what direction does
it go?
Right, it shifts toward
products.
Then you are in better shape to
climb your mountain.
Again, the same principles of
shifting reaction applying to a
biological system.